[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show this is a
powerful and unusual episode featuring
coach George raveling who made his first
appearance on the podcast in 2018 right
now I'm looking at a tweet from a
listener Ryan M who called it his
favorite podcast of all time that type
of feedback came in again and again for
me personally he was one of the most
impactful interviews I've ever done and
I came out of it walking on air
effectively coach raveling is really
much more than a coach of sports he is a
coach of life and has led many people
through difficult decisions difficult
periods difficult transitions we covered
a lot of ground in that first interview
including how coach raveling came to own
the original copy of dr. Martin Luther
King Junior's I have a dream speech how
his practice team ended up beating the
1984 US Olympic dream team in basketball
how he helped convince Michael Jordan to
sign with Nike and much much more you
can find it by going to teamed up blog
forward slash George raveling rav e Li
ng I strongly encourage you to listen to
that conversation when you can about
coach's life philosophies and lessons
learned I invited George back on the
podcast to hear his thoughts on
everything that is happening right now
these are obviously very difficult and
uncertain times for millions of people
and my heart goes out to each and every
person navigating the depths of sadness
anger fear and many other emotions right
now as you'll hear in today's episode
coach raveling has great hope he's seen
many changes in his lifetime and we can
all strive to be the positive change
agents that he implores us to be before
we get to today's conversation here is a
very brief bio which barely scratches
the surface coach George raveling on
Twitter at George raveling is an 82 year
old living legend and Nikes former
director of international basketball
coach raveling was the first African
American head basketball coach in the
PAC 8 now pac-12 on August 28th 1963 at
age 26 while volunteering as security at
the march on Washington raveling humbly
became the guardian of what we now know
as dr. Martin Luther King Junior's I
have a dream speech coach raveling has
held head coaching positions at
Washington State the University of Iowa
and USC following a prolific basketball
coaching career he joined Nike at the
request of Phil Knight where he played
an integral role in signing a reluctant
Michael Jordan he's also been inducted
into the Naismith Memorial Basketball
Hall of Fame and the National Collegiate
Basketball Hall of Fame please enjoy
this timely and very timeless
conversation with coach George raveling
coach I appreciate you taking time to
record this follow-up to our
conversation it is June 7th 2020
following the death of George Floyd a
lot is happening how or where would you
like to start I would like to start with
a prayer please do dear merciful God we
come before you on this day to request
that you compassionately welcome droid
Floyd into your heavenly kingdom please
restore his breath his heartbeat heal
his wounds allow him to live the life he
was denied on earth God showers some of
your richest gifts on the Floyd family
give them the strength during these
challenging times their God answered
Georgia's dying requests for his mother
please please unite them one more time
and finally dear Lord we ask you to
bring comfort and understanding to the
multitude of families who have suffered
the loss of their own
once during these times of social change
we make this request in your name amen
and then thank you for that George I
find myself in a very different place
than I normally would in these
conversations I come in with a long list
of questions I've typically done a lot
of homework on the person I'll be
speaking with and we've already had one
very very long conversation and covered
a lot but this is really a an afternoon
where I would like do more listening
than anything else and I would just love
to hear from you what you're what you're
observing or what you'd like to share
about yourself as a way of entering into
this conversation one of the things that
you might find intriguing tim is that I
have had a what I call a stop strategy
and I've had this for for years and
years and years and I feel it's so
applicable to the contemporary times and
the things that we're dealing with now I
think each of us are given one life to
live and each of us have a fundamental
responsibility to protect that vice and
to protect ourselves from death and when
I have conversations with myself I say
to myself I must never forget this
reality I am black forever and my number
one goal is to stay alive you know I'm
I'm 80 82 year old black man and I Drive
a black Lexus SUV and thus I feel I have
to have
stop strategy what do I do if I'm pulled
over by the police I've got to turn off
the motor I'm going to turn on the flow
and so I have some overt evidence of
what took place I'm gonna roll the
window down I'm going to put my hands
high up on the steering wheel so they
can it'll be obvious that I don't have
anything in my hands I'll be polite I'll
be overly polite now say yes sir and no
sir or yes ma'am and no ma'am and if
there's a request made for my license
I'll ask for permission to reach into my
pocket and pull it out I'll give them my
driver's license and I'll also give them
an old faculty ID card that I had from
when I was coaching at USC and then I'll
pray and at that moment now we have one
objective and that is to stay alive and
Tim that's really it comes a time when
you're when you you being a black person
we have to be confronted with this
reality and that reality is that we're
black forever but you know what the
burden of being black is something that
I welcome and hopefully it'll bring out
the best in me the very best in me and
and when all is said and done the only
truth validation I see is my self
validation I've grown to understand that
it's just senseless for me to struggle
for America's validation if I do that
Tim I'm always gonna be chasing a ghost
and so that's why as an 82 year old
black male I understand the importance
and relevance of having what I call a
stop strategy and have you ever had to
use that or have you used it outside as
do you have other stop strategies for
outside of the automobile how else what
other strategies have you carried with
yourself throughout life as a black male
do any come to mind as you relate to
being stopped by a policeman that's as
simple as I've been pulled over for on
Thompson and and to be totally
transparent if it was if I grant a white
or I had a speeding ticket I clearly
understand that but I also recognize
that there's a protocol that the law
enforcement has to engage in and so I'm
not going to ever assume that that my
life is not at risk and and so I I want
to be I want to be prepared when it if
something like that happens sadly I feel
like I'd reached a point in life where I
have to live my life on defense I've got
a worry more about someone else's
deportment or behavior than my own and I
realized that as I said I'll forever be
black so I I have to expect that there's
going to be certain preconceived ideas
about me as a black male people people
say they know me Tim but they don't they
don't really know me and I could
honestly say you in my lifetime
that most people have never really tried
to know me they have a surface
impression of me
and maybe one of our challenges is to
try to to better understand each other I
don't put an indictment on people but I
feel I'm guilty of that I think I need
to know people better I need I need to
feel their pain I need to understand
that they're carrying somebody else's
cross hmm
and you mentioned impressions
misconceptions I want to mention for
people who perhaps didn't listen to part
one because I imagine a lot of people
will jump to this very timely as at the
time of recording conversation we're
having now but you own probably more
than $100,000 worth of black
collectibles including figurines books
postcards first edition of Uncle Tom's
Cabin and some of these are very
derogatory but black person eating
watermelon with a smile on his face on a
postcard for instance and some of the
notes themselves written on those
postcards are very derogatory and I
remember from our first conversation you
started to build this historic
collection so that you could have a
legacy for your children and their
children why is that I think that one
their historical I need a constant
reminder of times gone by and how we how
we arrived at where we are today I I
used to go to the post to post card
antique shows and I would go and search
out there vendors who who sold postcards
I have over $1,000 and back to the point
Tim when when you need to have to put
stamp on them and one common denominator
of them all is the derogatory pictures
of black folks eating watermelon the big
lips smiling like
the subtle references or influences that
look they happy they're not bewildered
day look look we we treat them good look
they smile it and they remind me also to
tell a story of this long journey of
inequity and and injustice and so I've
collected the cards I mean if you if you
were to read some of the messages on
there their abominable but it's a remind
me of the long road we've traveled and
the wrong road that we still have to
travel to become who we say we are I say
something to you Tim that that's been a
little bit surprising to me is and it's
somewhat of a personal phenomena but as
of this moment that we speak I can I
could report to you that 85% of my white
friends and associates have not called
me and so I think it begs some questions
you do I think they're obligated
absolutely not
am i mad at them or disappointed no do I
think it would be helpful yes
so then the question is why I think it's
another overt example in my opinion it's
because people don't know what to say I
I get it
most of us are not ready and we're not
good at having real conversations we're
not good at having difficult
conversations
because real conversations challenge us
real conversations and difficult
conversations in my opinion they make us
stand in our own truth and they teach us
that we have to be truth tellers and we
got a we got to listen to learn and not
only that I think we have to learn to
ask intelligent questions we are
two-sided we are the problem and we are
the solution you and I have have chatted
recently and you've mentioned the
importance of honest conversations and
the one thing you've you've mentioned to
me that I'd love to hear you elaborate
on as you said you know honest
conversations with others and honest
conversations with ourselves what do you
mean by that well first of all Jim when
someone says hey a coach or hey George I
like that I want to meet with you I want
to can I have like to talk to you about
something so immediately I go and start
to have a conversation with myself and
the first thing I say to myself is this
going to be a conversation or is this
going to be a debate because it's
totally different you know some people
that they frame it as a conversation but
it really becomes a debate because if
it's a debate it's about winning and
losing it's about right and wrong and I
surrender right from the beginning I'll
gladly say you're right
I'm wrong because I you get in the
conversation and the person sole intent
is to prove to you that they are right
and you are wrong or hopefully they can
get you to be
who they want you to be in and think
like they want you to think that thing
to have a real conversation
the first thing a person's got to do is
they've got to have to have the
willingness sustained in their own truth
and they've got to be willing to tell
the truth and I believe people have to
listen to learn and to understand God
knows that there is ever in time in our
lives and we need to listen to learn and
understand it's it's at there at this
time right now and another thing that I
think to have a real conversation isn't
that's a govern our talk to listen ratio
and to go back to put more clarity on
the question that you asked I think some
of the most important conversations we
can have each day are the conversations
that we had with ourselves there's
basically two conversations we engage in
the conversations with others and the
conversation with ourselves and and I do
believe that probably the most important
conversations we'll have are the
conversations we have with ourselves
when we listen to our inner voice and
and we talk and in many ways I believe
right now to the most important words of
an English language are we and us as a
society I would really like to see us
have more conversations about life and
death and right and wrong I really think
we do ourselves a disservice when we
don't deal with the fundamentals the
fundamentals of life and there's nothing
more fundamental than a life and what
gives one human being the audacity to
think that they have the right to take
someone else's life what is it
that would make one human being totally
devalue and disrespect the life of
another human being regardless of what
color they are it's just human arrogance
that that one could be so disrespectful
of the greatest gift of all the gift of
a life and why don't we have
conversations around that fundamental
aspect and why is it that we don't have
meaningful discussions about right or
wrong I think in some ways Tim I think
each of us tend to see the world through
our own lenses I don't know maybe maybe
it'd be helpful if we would attempt to
see the world through the lens of others
in it I know one thing for sure it would
give us a balanced perspective I was
just gonna say and I think it also
making an attempt to do that can diffuse
some of the reactivity or emotion that
can escalate things and cause greater
problems and one thing you said to me in
our last conversation was that and I'm
paraphrasing here so please feel free to
correct but it relates to what you just
said you said if you start with white
and black or white versus black black
versus white immediately many people on
both sides are going to be in the
defensive and it's going to become like
you said earlier a debate and would it
not be more helpful to try to go to a
higher level where you can find some
shared experience or shared important
questions to to to at least begin the
conversation so that not everyone is in
debate form and and reactive so I just
wanted to echo that because it came to
mind as you're speaking it did a hard
reality is this that many days we spend
more time talking to the screen than we
do face
faced with a human being and I've kind
of grown in the latter years of my life
to understand that I'm a product of an
educational system that was based on
telling me what to do and what to think
instead of teaching me how to think and
so so much of my time now is spent
trying to teach myself how to thing and
there's so much time that I I have to
make up because of the fact that I
didn't ever really understand the
relevance or importance of being able to
think because someone always told me
what to think and in many ways as a
black person growing up in a variety of
ways there's always someone telling you
we know what's best for you if I don't
know what's best for me then how to help
can somebody else think they know what's
best for me if you flashback to the
civil rights movement for people who may
have jumped ahead and skipped our first
conversation you own the original copy
of the what later became known as the I
have a dream speech dr. Martin Luther
King jr. handed you this speech himself
as he came off of the Dyess because you
were you ended up through an amazing
story which people can listen to part
one for you ended up working security as
a volunteer and were handed this speech
so you've you've been in the thick of so
many defining moments in the history of
this country certainly as it relates to
civil rights
what are some of the differences that
you see or commonalities that you see
when you look back at your experience in
the civil rights movement you look at
what's happening right now
hi I think that I keep going back every
day and I have these inner conversations
with myself about life and death and
that's one thing that hasn't changed is
for a lot of us it's still about life
and death
I remember watching a documentary on
television and it was about the lunch
counter demonstrations in Greensboro in
years gone by and the leader of the
demonstrators they were having a meeting
and church and at the end of the meeting
the leader said to the demonstrators he
said before y'all leave I need you to do
something I need you to hug everybody in
this room and tell him that you love him
he said and I want you to every one of
you can do it no matter how long it
takes and and I want you to tell me
goodbye
he said because tomorrow night willing
me
some of y'all ain't gonna be here and it
goes back to that same thing our lives
and I to this day I'm so startled but
the courage that those students had
I don't know when I was 18 or 19 or 20
and I was a student at Villanova
if I would have had the courage to put
my life on the line and know that
tomorrow night I might not be back and
Tim so much of this we would like to
think it's about black and white and it
is but it's it's about life it's about
human life and III see I don't know if I
could have done it I don't know if I
it's like uh if I had to I'm sure I
would Martin Luther King used to say if
a man or woman hasn't found something in
life you're willing to die for it and
maybe they're not fit to live and there
comes that seminal moment every one of
our lives where we have to say to myself
do I live or do our die and so it's
tough you know you something just popped
in my mind you were asking me about
about the collections in that and
something popped in my mind I just think
if we don't understand our past him in
our present there's no be no future and
so they're symbolic evidence of the past
but if I don't understand my past and my
present I have no future and when you
think about building a future and
crafting a path towards a future that is
better than today one distinction that
you've drawn in our previous
conversations is group leadership versus
I think you put it as self leadership
could you speak to what the
means if you were to go into the
bathroom in my house right now
Tim in the middle of the mirror in the
mirror nothing in the main bathroom is
probably six well maybe that's six we
bring forth four feet long and it's very
rectangular and in the middle of it I
have a sign up there and I taped it so I
have to see it every day and every
morning and every evening and times
throughout the day and the sign simply
says practice and then underneath it has
two statements self leadership and self
discipline and I don't think that
there's any more relevant or important
time to practice those we say and
rightfully so that we're lacking in
leadership
I've asked numerous of my friends over
the last few months
Tim this question tell me who you think
are the five greatest leaders on the
globe right now and none of them can be
a corporate executive and I am not
getting one single person who could get
past three names and so I say that's
overt evidence that that we are in the
midst of a leadership crisis a deficit
but I do know that if one were to go to
library Congress and look up books on
leadership there would be over 3,000
books written on leadership but those
books all speak to group leadership
there are three or four books on self
leadership robert greenlease book is
the most problem it this is a this is
the 48 laws of power by Robert Greene
green this is a book by a green leaf
greenness and it's on self-leadership
and so to me if you can't lead yourself
how in the world are you going to lead
anybody else and for many of us the only
person were ever going to get the lead
is ourselves and so I can continue to
say we we have bad leadership where we
lack in readership okay but I have a
responsibility to lead myself in these
times of turmoil and then the second
part of that science is to be
self-discipline and so I think if
nothing else I have to serve as a overt
example of someone who recognizes the
need for leadership and recognizes that
I can control myself leadership and I
can exercise my self-discipline and so
but so much of my life as has kind of
never changed him most of my life has
been governed by a simple form would
survive and thrive
I mean if I could take you back to June
27 1937 a little a little black boy was
born in the basement of a segregated
Hospital in Washington DC and they gave
that baby the name George and he was
born in the basement of this segregated
hospital called Garfield
and it was that lovely florid Adnan and
blacks will only could enter the
hospital from from the back and they had
to go down to the basement and so the
first breath as a human being that that
I breathe was the air from the air of
segregation and from that moment on I've
had to figure out how do I survive when
I was growing up in Washington DC that
the city was 73 percent black today it's
45 percent black the lowest it's slipped
under 50 percent for the first time in
50 years when you hear people use
connotation chocolate city
Washington DC was the original chocolate
city with 73 percent of the population
and so this black boy child George or
Adam he lived over a meat market and
over the meat market on the second floor
there were three apartments and none of
them had a bathroom there was a bathroom
at the end of the hallway that had a
commode a sink and a tub and the three
families who lived in those apartments
we had to learn to be so discipline we
had the practices of leadership we had
to figure out how three families could
use one commode one seat and one bath
but we made it we made it work and I
then we we lived on the corner of
Florida abner in the church you know and
you could walk from from there to what
is now Howard University but at that
time when I was young boy Washington had
a baseball team called the Washington
Senators and people were fond as saying
first in war first in peace and last an
American League I think but they played
their games in Griffin Stadium and I
couldn't walk to the Griffin Stadium
from my where I lived and so I used to
walk up there and I got a job selling
scorecards and the old days in baseball
he didn't have the technology and so
forth and so that the fans would have a
scorecard and they would keep this the
data and the score on a scorecard and so
what you did she stood outside the
stadium and you and you Sol scorecards
and pencils and I also tried to deliver
it or did delivered newspapers to make
some little extra money in those days
Tim if you were black
you didn't have the luxury to jury some
people say when you a little kid you
dream every dream you're going to be a
culturist
dreaming for a black person in those
days was a luxury you got up every
morning and you looked out at the world
and the textile stands and you've tried
to figure out how can I survive you had
no dreams you had no hopes
it was literally all about surviving
from day to day and Here I am at the age
82 and I still grapple with the same
thing how can I survive and how can I
Drive Here I am and the reality is this
I'm an 82 year old
blackmail a former basketball coach and
so the challenge for me is how can I
remain relevant in an ever-changing
world and what is it that I don't know
but I need to know to stay relevant
there's different times and different
faces in different places but the
fundamental has you change how do I
survive and how do I thrive
and you're a a voracious reader I mean
your your nickname which people might
remember from the first conversation is
the human Google I mean you you have
read thousands upon thousands of books
and just to just to clarify you
mentioned the name Robert Greenleaf is
that the book sir I just pulled it up
here servant-leadership
subtitle a journey of nature and the
subtitle is a journey into the nature of
legitimate power and greatness which yet
has has been a classic it looks like for
25 years at this point are there any
other books that have helped you in
developing your own ability to self lead
or to improve self discipline to any
other resources or practices come to
mind that you've found particularly
helpful one of the books that I found
helpful and and when I say helpful if I
read something in a book that causes me
to change my behavior then I I feel I
really found something that unique and
special I read a book many years ago by
Mark McCormick called things they don't
teach that hardly Business School man
it's always been one of my my favorite
the true believer by Eric Haase wasn't
another book
the owners tons of books I could make I
tell you this him a book I'm reading
right now I would ask all
all of our listeners to divide this book
and it's called tell me who you are it
should be mandatory reading for anyone
who wants to understand why we are in
the situation we are today not from the
pandemic but in all the other areas of
inequity in our social system I don't
want to talk too much about the book
it's written by two women
it's an extraordinary book and I thought
I knew a lot about racial injustice I
thought I understood a lot of things
about the least of God's children but
when I read this book it's very hard for
me to read more than three pages and I
don't start to tear up but if you buy
this book buy it with the intent to
learn and understand otherwise if you're
just buying it for an entertainment
don't buy it it's a book that's going to
cause you to have difficult
conversations with yourself it's a book
that's going to reveal what I call the
other America there's a actually was a
book written that was that we emphasis
for the war on poverty but there was a
book written called the other America by
Michael Harrington and so I borrowed
that phrase the other America there's an
America out there that we don't know but
we need to know about I don't know two
to let young ladies who wrote the book I
I'm not trying to promote ourselves
I'm just trying to tell you if you
really really want to understand and you
want to learn you got to read this book
and you don't have to read it all at
once because it's going to be hard
do because because because you don't cry
you're gonna feel guilty
you're gonna humanity sing Wow hug one
person see another person like this they
tell me who you are
is by Wynonna Guo GU oh and pre avulsion
I'll certainly link to that in the show
notes for this this conversation as well
so people will be able to find that at
tim dot blog slash podcast and just
search your name the question i'd love
to explore with you georges what you
would say to people right now who are
really angry because as you said you
know you you some of these first-person
accounts certainly many people have had
personal experiences that are just
reflective of such gross injustice such
mistreatment and you have a lot of
people right now who are angry of of all
different colors and creeds what would
you say to people who are feeling
consumed by anger at the moment i would
want to questions and i would want to
listen i would want to understand in
greater depth why they're angry because
i don't want to assume the obvious the
obvious is never the obvious the problem
is that we think is never the front once
you attack a problem what you thought
was the real problem was never the real
problem once you get going deals
discovered a real problem so i want to
listen and i want to understand and not
assume that i know why this person is
angry and i think in many ways all of us
need to be angry and we need to be
befuddle in that because i truly believe
that we live in a country and we we live
a lie and what i mean by that is
if you pick up our paper currency it
says united states of Vermont if you go
back to the framer the framers say we
the people but in many ways we're living
the lie because we're not who we say we
are
we're not United and it's not about the
people and these lies they're just going
to hold us in hostage but the truthful
will free us and to me the system is
built to separate us not just by race
the system is built to marginalize us we
talk about red states and blue states
and form Belton Rust Belt and Democrats
and and Republicans and conservatives
and tea parties and rich people and
we're all have these boxes that someone
wants to put us in and all these labels
America leads the world and labels
everything that I've got to have a label
on it and so my fundamental question is
this why does there have to be a box
boxes have four walls and at some point
they fill up with four walls it limits
my movement so why do I have to operate
from a box the first thing intelligence
tells me if I'm in a box it impedes my
ability to reach for my outer limits as
a human being so if we allow people to
keep us in boxes how will one ever reach
their outer limits how will one ever be
able to answer the question Who am I
if I don't get a chance to explore my
out of limits
I know who I am and why I'm honored and
what is it that I'm capable of being so
in many ways in this country we're
living alive we've got to get back to a
point where we are who we say we are
we're either United oh we're not United
it's either about We the People or it's
not about we'd the people as the common
language of America became not English
but money our language should not be the
language of money and I just get I say
to myself that I do really believe this
at 82 years old I'm finally got my
freedom I'm free to do what I want to do
when I want to do it how I want to do it
I'm free to try to discover my outer
limits I'm free to be who God meant for
me to be
I honestly and truly believe that the
last couple of years in my life that I I
can honestly kind of feel what Martin
Luther King said when he spoke at the
steps of the Lincoln Memorial free at
last free at last thank God Almighty I'm
free at last it's the first time that in
my existence on this planet that I could
are sensical believe that I'm a free
human being that I can pursue my outer
limits what changed
why what was the catalyst or the
realization the realization was
that the system is built to create
average people you go to school you get
an average education you get an average
job
you live in an average neighborhood you
live an average amount of time and and
the world is populated with average
people and I'm so glad that I live long
enough that I could feel the necessity
to be uncommon in some ways maybe I was
born as one of God's the least of his
children but I've been truly blessed to
be on this planet for 82 years and I'll
be able to die knowing that I didn't die
in the societal box that I was free
enough to try to reach for my my outer
limits and to explore that phrase a bit
exploring your outer limits I mean it it
seems to imply to me both an awareness
of the box that you've been put in or
put yourself in and then a willingness
to try to transcend that what does that
look like does it look like broad
reading does it look like uncommon
action for you personally what has
exploring your outer limits looked like
it's all built around a fundamental
question that I have to ask myself time
and time again what is it that I don't
know but I need to know what is it that
I don't know but need to know when I was
a student at doe Nova and and I was on
basketball scholarship or our coach said
towards one time
and maybe left an indelible mark on my
brain with this quote he said the first
sign of intelligence is to admit that
you don't know something so I'm trying
to find out what it is that I don't know
but I need to know so that I can have a
relevance on the remaining time I'm here
on the globe and that's the simple
processes you've got to take the fences
down and around you because as long as
people can build fences around you they
can keep you where they want you and
they want you to be average and I don't
want to be average I want to be uncommon
is part of and this is a leading
question but I'm curious is part of
keeping those fences down not applying
too many labels to yourself I just think
I'm thinking back to the list that you
gave earlier you know liberal
progressive this that a versus B C
versus D because I've never I don't
think I've ever heard you use any of
those labels applied to yourself at
least in our in our conversations that
we've had I don't know if that's just
because of the nature of the
conversations that we've had but are
there other ways that you keep the
fences down yeah because the first thing
is to recognize that there is a fence
people don't examine when someone is
quick to put a label on you and
encourage you to live in this box the
first thing you got a rail start to do
is start actually have a conversation
with yourself and start asking questions
and so to me I'm aware of these fences
and and I refuse to allow someone to
build the fence around me
because intentionally or unintentionally
I'm about to come to a standstill
because the more people that are in that
box unless my mobility is and I think we
also what was the thing that I've been
telling myself about what is it that I
don't know but I need to know I've come
to recognize that I need to develop 21st
century skills kind of strangely you get
that be 82 and you start thinking about
this but once again when I asked that
question how can I stay relevant if I'm
going to be relevant I've got to be able
to develop 21st century skills and I'm
gonna anticipate you saying well coach
what our 21st century skills are I think
you have to develop a skill set that are
transferable and sustainable in the 21st
century there's there's so obvious
leadership and communication and just
not all communication but written
communication relationships as long as
we live there's going to have to be
leadership so we're going to have to
communicate we're going to have to have
relationships problem solving decision
making information that is a critical
thing 10 are we going to a teamwork
analytical thinking so what I try to do
is take one of those and for six months
read as much as I can about one up so
that I can better understand how I can
equip myself because I've got it eight
defenses down I got a I got an either
pulling down or I get an hour I and I
can once I pull them down I got to get
rid of forever and so once I take those
fences down
I can't pop the cork and think of what
all I've done this is free of my ability
of a movement and so now I got it I've
got it
equip myself with these 21st century
skills particularly at 82 years old
because the last thing I want to be as a
relic and protect myself from becoming a
relic I got to be able to compete in the
21st century I've got to be able to
compete with young people not just old
people I need I need to compete with
young people I need to understand young
people these young people are our future
and I feel bad for our young people
because they're the ones that are gonna
inherit this mess and they're the ones
that are gonna have to fix it and I feel
so bad for our grandchildren and
children and in general these young
people we're leaving a mess son and they
inevitably they're gonna have to excel
in these skills because they're the ones
who are going to have to figure out what
to do with this mess that we left under
door what one of the one of the
things I enjoy about our interactions
George is that your your men of ideas
and concepts but you're also a man of
action you do a lot and it's it's
informed action there are millions of
people right now I'm sure probably tens
hundreds of millions who are unsure of
what to do and perhaps also afraid of
doing the wrong thing and I'd be curious
to know if you have any advice for
people who are feeling a need to do
something but don't know what to do of
course
we see we've seen a lot of statements
that have been issued if you have any
thoughts on statements what form they
should take if any I just love to hear
your thoughts for those who feel like
they should or need to do something but
are unsure of what to do well two days
one what can one do just be simple just
let it start with yourself start with
you and and do your part I'm going to
come back to this public statement thing
but what I would like to ask and you did
is a partial answer to what can we do I
would like to ask each of those who are
listening to this interview can take a
pledge I would like you to write this
down and take this pledge if you want to
know what you can do is this and the
pledges I encouraged I'm going to
encourage each of our listeners to do
this and the pledges I will fully commit
to being a positive change agent a
positive difference maker and in many
lives as possible it doesn't take money
it doesn't matter what race you are it's
just a simple pledge it's got to start
correcting the wrongs have to start with
our behavior and so I want to say that
again I got if you ever want to do
something for me just take this pledge
and live it I will fully commit to being
a positive change agent a positive
difference maker and in as many lives as
possible we don't have to be rich you
know it doesn't make any difference if
you're poor doesn't make any difference
if you're black or white
you can control this nobody can take
this away from this nobody can take this
commitment away from you to be a
positive change agent to be a positive
difference maker to be kind to people it
might not change the world
but if you say one might that one life
will have a rippling effect and it'll
save another life and another life and
another life and before you know it
we'll wake up one morning and we will
have made significant change in up in
the world and then this place we call
America that's what I would like to do
as you say what can a person do that's
my answer to that that the public
statement thing honestly I've kind of
grown worried of corporate and
organizational we got enough in my
opinion most of it's insincere anyway in
at blacks and substance coming in these
statements are really solution based and
there's so-called statements to me in
many ways are overt evidence of our
inability to tell the truth what do you
mean what do you mean there is it
there's a there's a difference Tim
between the statement and a message so
yeah that's the thing
everybody runs around I can't believe
how many corporate executives and
organizational people feel like they
have to make a statement I've had
friends call and say hey I got to make a
statement what should I say
and once I've asked you that I said the
first thing is don't make a statement
give it make a message messages tell a
story that that that resonates with the
listeners messages are a commitment you
know we ultimately when it's all said
and done our words must be manifested
within our behavior anything shorter
that and we live in a lie
and I just think at some point we can
make all the statements we want but the
reality is that we have to rise to a
higher moral level and if corporations
today I don't know me personally I
appreciate their paper courtesy but what
I really think that society needs from
our corporations is their intellectual
currency I think history replete with
evidence that throwing money at the
problem is rarely going to be
dissolution one of the questions I have
with with this money part is comma
submit will be specifically used to
enrich the lives of our young people and
their futures because we're leaving
leaving them a message that can clean up
I think that what I would like to do is
to tap into the intellectual currency of
corporate America and and they've got
some of the most elite thinkers on the
planet in corporations and so it a group
of corporations come together in a
collaborative manner and create programs
to help enrich the lives of our young
people and help prepare our young people
to successfully deal with this mess that
we're leaving them so can corporations
create mentor programs so somebody's
gonna raise their hand and say we have
one can they create intern programs can
they you
like their intellectual currency to help
young people develop these 21st century
skills can they provide technology and
the technology tools such as laptops and
computers for young people then we teach
young people how to think God knows if
there's ever something that we could do
that would help young people is to teach
them how to think stop teaching them
what the thing teach them how to think
we've got some of the greatest minds on
the planet housing these corporations
and I just think that they have a moral
obligation to target the least of God's
children I think our young children out
there are pregnant with possibilities
for greatness but we got to help them
discover it Tim and Mike in my lifetime
and this is not an indictment on my
parents there was never a time in my
life when my mom or my dad or my grandma
have ever said to me George when you
grow up you're going to go to college
Cal they never finished school how hell
are you think that your son I mean there
did their childhoods and going to
college it was black people couldn't
dream like that in those days but we had
there's so many undiscovered young folks
out there they need somebody to say a
simple phrase to them I believe in you
you know how many kids have never had
our human beings say to them I believe
in you
corporate America can put together all
these elite dangers and they don't just
have to say I believe
you but they can put the programs
together that allowed that that person
to believe in themselves
I will never fully buy into throwing
money at it it's the answer you just
made me think George that if I try to
canvas
everyone I've interviewed on this
podcast you know close to 500 people now
I would say the one of the commonalities
would have to be that at some point
someone said I believe in you maybe it
wasn't in childhood but at some point
some mentor some father figure or mother
figure or supporter said I believe in
you and so today raises a lot of a lot
of questions and also brings to mind a
lot of possible actions for ladies until
it's not sufficient hey I believe that
you and then don't
don't let your your and then your
behavior has to reflect what you just
said I believe in you there's definitely
mention of goodness and intellect in all
of us tonight until I got to Villanova
it wasn't until I got the phone number
that I found myself intellectually I
didn't know who I was I didn't even
really understand how important it was
to be it going over to be a student and
then learn I can remember this so
vividly by the sophomore year because
when I went to don't know if you had to
wear a shirt and tie to class and yeah
and you had to sit by alphabet that's
not acceptable for all and I graduated
with a BS in economics but it was until
my sophomore year and I started to find
myself intellectually I had I hear guys
say that guys you're really smart man
maybe you should get him to help and
there would be a
number of people in my classes that
people would identify his being really
smart and so I would listen to them and
I would observe them and honestly Tim
and myself talk there were a number
times when I said so I think I'm as
smart as him and that was the beginning
of me trying to discover myself
intellectually I didn't have a frame of
reference no one ever told me that I was
smart no one ever told me that the only
way I ended up in college was because of
basketball the scholarship I didn't
really understand it all and if there
was if I had to do it all over I
honestly believe I could have been an
honor student I didn't understand it I
didn't know that I took that education
could take me to places they did and
helped me learn how to be a better human
being
it took a long time I've kind of been
running from behind most of my life a
guy told me one time if a man gets
behind at a race he must forever remain
behind or run faster than the man in
front and then I've been on the sprint
for about the last 40 years
it's an incredible life story I mean I I
don't know how you have managed to to
cram so much into your lifetime which
granted is 82 years thus far but it's
still you know a blink of a blink of the
eye in some respects it's it's really
just incredible and it in for those
people who are listening who are say
parents of kids and difficult
circumstances
maybe they themselves don't have many
resources aside from the I believe in
you and behavior to support that
besides the the pledge which you
mentioned earlier about being a positive
change agent and positive difference
maker would you have any advice for
those for those parents for people who
are trying to raise their kids and
enable them in the greatest way path
I think it's so difficult to be a parent
today because at one time I used to
think it was a black problem but today I
think it's a societal problem we live in
a society of the day where most of the
young people are raised in a
single-parent household my nine years at
USC I only coach two black players who
came from a dual parent household so the
first issue is the parent and when we
say is usually going to be the mother
because of our judicial system the court
usually award the child to the mother
and so those what mothers aren't true
so-called American heroes they work two
and three jobs most parents will do
things for their children they would
never do for themselves
and so it's such an enormous challenge
now to raise a child I think that you
just have to try as hard as you can to
provide the best for your children and
teach them a sustainable value system of
right and wrong of perseverance I don't
know I I don't know if I'm equipped to
say because I'm still trying to raise
myself hmm what are your your hopes for
what could come of this turbulent time
these turbulent times I should say
certainly that are really sort of
exhibiting and showing to us ruptures
that have existed for a long time what
what are some of your hopes for what can
come out of this and what are some of
your fears of what might come out of
this if you have any my hope is that we
will be
who we say we are all of us that if we
are the United States of America then we
need to start to live it and and not
continue to live a lie that is my hope
as we we proceed that as I said earlier
in the conversation where's a problem
and weirdest solution yeah we are the
problem and we are the solution well
George I want to be respectful of your
time we've covered a lot I'm not in any
rush I can continue to go as long as you
would like to go but is is there
anything else you would like to to say
or share that's not I think we touched a
lot of the sensitive nerves and that
when we conclude I would just like to
conclude this the same way we started
but it may be you there's some things
that that you think merits some
discussion I'm open to it I think we've
covered a lot of ground
I think we've and by we I mean you you
have offered some some direction a lot
of recommendation you've offered
resources like tell me who you are
of course we'll link to all of these
things you mentioned Robert Greenleaf
and certain leadership as far as
resources go many different takeaways
that people can I think apply or at the
very least think about but as you
mentioned you know if we put words into
our heads or out into the world what
matters is the behavior that follows
those and the practice like you have on
your on your bathroom mirror of self
leadership and self discipline since you
need to lead yourself before you can
hope to lead any type of group and I
think we're at a good place where we
could we could end the way we started
for now I would just like that
to conclude what the way I started with
the prayer and my prayer is dear God
please help us unite as a nation please
help us be who we say we are a United
States of America amen amen
thank you so much for taking the time to
share your the breadth and richness of
your life experience and also the
insights that you've come to after
eighty-two years on this planet I really
appreciate you taking the time George
thank you Jim and I appreciate that the
opportunity and more importantly I
appreciate this legend thank you so much
and you are such a positive change agent
and I think as you said if you do save
one life that has ripple effects I think
your positive impact on so many people
has a real incredible ripple effect so I
would just say please keep doing what
you're doing I really appreciate you
thank you thank you and to everybody
listening we will have links to
everything that we discussed in the show
notes and you can find that as always a
Tim top blog forward slash podcast and
simply search for George's name and in
fact what we'll do is create a short
link which will just be Tim dot blog
forward slash George and that will take
us all to the resources specifically for
this episode and until next time thank
you for tuning in be kind be safe and
always strive to be the person you say
you are
thank you hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me and would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm all
the spell out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
[Applause]